everyone we are here to discuss vessels
about this new book that do a voyage
that new dodgy process of the cell city
tomorrow which has just been published
by getting back in the affected cells
humans collection and there's a nice
serendipity for this event this evening
because just last week there was a
review a glowing review which
characterized it as you need to the it
movie soft and which furthermore
insisted on the fact that it was not
just a literary analysis of ethnographic
texts but also an extremely ambitious
reflection on the history of literature
on the history of anthropology and
history of the relationships complex
relationships between them and so we
will touch on some of those ambitions
tonight I think so
Bessel and I are going to have an
so what informal exchange with some
questions about the book then we're
gonna open the floor for your questions
and I would also like to let you know
that we were hoping to have copies of
the book available for you to buy this
evening but they were as usual held up
at customs so we do have one copy of the
book and also a copy of the play I've
edition of the V's closest words that
been so coordinated and prefaced and
also an order form such that you can buy
the order of the book with the free
shipping and discount so don't hesitate
to take advantage of that and also to
take a look at the the books that are on
display over there and then we will have
a reception since this is also an
occasion to celebrate the publication of
the book to which you are all cordially
invited so that's all I thought we could
start with talking a little bit about
titles important part of the book I know
that at one point you had considered
middle for the let no cop and then
eventually came to this title
some of the ideas that are behind those
titles and some of the discussions that
you had with your editor that led you to
come to this the title that yeah so
thank you thank you for thank you for
making this possible
yeah the original title was literally
two books and because the starting point
I mean the point of departure was some
sort of bibliographic curiosity I was
studying the writings of the first
generation of French ethnographers my
first generation I mean the first
generation for which fieldwork was a
request with requirement so it was the
generation trained by most mainly muscle
most may need that in the 20s so I was
studying those writings and I came to
realize that most of the ethnographers
almost all of them we're writing of
course a very specialized
murder graph about certain right certain
linguistic family certain social
manifestation and addition to that they
must almost all of them gave published
more literally accounts of their field
experience some sort of so it was
published by much more it was intended
for a wider audience it was published by
not by the music learn more than Emily
gets may get mouth I said so of course
the question was why two books I mean
why
what is the relationship what is why do
another police feel the need for you
know the Literary Supplement
to their scientific work and maybe I
should give some examples I mean the
most to most famous examples disclose
who wrote letters for media associate
social and family life of Nami correct
interns in 1948 and then seven years
later gave me the topic you also live is
giving a long success on gravity the
scientific work and then so yeah so that
was the first title they don't even know
that was the first idea and then he did
you kill no I did not I guess it was not
sexy
it was not really not fun you know and
and so I guess he's reliable
so he told me he told me I think when I
say that because he actually he was
actually the one who coined the phrase
limo initials because who wanted to
entitle a lot of these shows but the
order of things which is a
mistranslation but it was not possible
for juridical reason and nobody shows
was a novel so we had to coin another
and so I said what would be greatly that
you have way ash in the title and I said
well why ash the thing is one of the
claims of the book is that there is
discontinuity between traditional
writing and anthropology so if Y as in
the book then it has to be you know sort
of critical way only just to be denied
so I don't want to call it that founded
well yeah and maybe she's still an
illusion to leave the school because at
the end of it you have this famous
summation and you solutions so
and you insist in the book on the fact
that the division between these two
books and the way that they are
configured is not always the same for
you death the different authors that
you're looking at and that the function
of the second book is not always the
same you want
yeah yes this is something important
because I mean first of all the
treasurer of the per second book fairies
I mean it can be any more big it can be
some sort of surrealistic the I really
like lastly contour it can be very
conventional traveler like Mexico
yeah my sister it can be very fun to
chronicle so the second book are not all
similar and but all of them I still
explicitly connected to the scientific
counterpart and I think it's important
because it's you know all those pairs
don't line up together and it's
important because it prevents from
reducing the relationship between the
two books to usual divide the objective
on the one hand the subjective on the
other hand narration on the one hand
description on the other hand
explanation on the one hand
interpretation so that's why it's really
I mean that's this is an important yeah
an important point I want my mother to
make and so it it shows that you need to
really locate each of these fairs in a
new geological context in a historical
context and not take for granted any
given division between
okay and that's actually precisely the
next thing that I wanted to ask you
about is the the review in the Moldavia
emphasizes the ambitions of the project
and part of the that the ambitious
nature of the project is the general
reflection that you start with about
these big categories of science and
literature and how they are configured
at different periods in literary history
and in the history of science and so one
of the things that struck me in reading
the book is that
you say that in dealing with these
there's certain challenge methodological
challenges in dealing with these big
categories that are sort of historical
historically changing categories and you
say that you take a lesson from the
ethnographer himself I guess in most
cases here to apply it to your own
method as a literary critic or scholar
you want to tell us about about that and
perhaps reflect more generally
yeah well nudge where I just say that in
the beginning of the book that the
danger I talked about the Denver of the
projecting categories on the two books
and again we have nice trying to
recognize like it's the way it's usually
you know dumb is that you have the visto
striking elementary structures of
kinship and then you have live East
Coast
there's food scientists and then you're
exposed to the man in other magazine
emotions is affect writing is a copy
because the Objectivists of just tested
approach of science would prevent
subjectivity from expressing itself so
and the thing is that you could do that
about anything so I thought it I thought
it more productive just just to look at
the text I mean to start with a very
careful history of knowledge careful
readings of a debt to situate locate the
text so and maybe you know distinguish
between two generations the ethnography
doing at the Museum of Africa DeVoe in
1928 is not quite the same one that in
the museum in 1938 and it's very
different from the
made in number one in the love of art or
associate enacted nineteen sixties so
but maybe I should give some more maybe
more examples
and just to give an example to
understand what how does this divide or
distribution work would be alpha tomato
his book on Easter Island so after we
talk well went online in 1934 he went to
mr. Allen he spent there eight months he
after he went back to France and then he
went spent three years in Hawaii
studying Polynesians population society
and in came he came up with this big
book ethnology of Easter Island 450
pages with all the details can imagine
the original texts of the legends
cessation lots of reflections about the
language the culture the riots and
everything and then in addition to that
one year later he publishes
Easter in the back which is a much more
jury account of his fieldwork in which
is published by 8941
and this booty the back was considered
by gravity said mrs. messages this is a
master he's not better than you know
most of the novels published today so
now of course the question is how do you
how do you account for this supplement
and so all those again oh this case on
off peril but in the case of Metro Metro
was a very very attentive careful notes
and most one of the one of the great
innovation brought by Yuri
either the social fact is the mental
fact it's a moral set so I mean what
make society what makes a society
typical it's not just material
productions or even a social
organization or even juridical rules
what make a society
typical is certain manners of thinking
man of the Quixote which are some
falsity first most naughty which is
which are phrases coming from - the kind
of actually and you get fellow trace you
know given how such a phrase like if I
some from City for some sense here is
starting from it's going from the
kindest realist because I mentioned that
a lot in the most livable so anyway and
and yet so you have like several texts
by most well in which must insist that
society is an atmosphere and you have an
atmosphere immoral to knowledge even
more planets and so of course the
question is how do you account for a
more Clement
and bit ho he's the one who who was
actually saying okay we need to do that
with a literary technique is the most
explicit really wondering I should I
mean he's any reason in Hawaii he writes
a letter to delirious and say you know
what I wanna I want to give the
impression on what is it the life form
Easter Island and to do that I need to
be a novelist I need to do it to be a
novelist attune to use the technique
borrow from the novel and so there is
what one of the striking things about
this this thing is that
resurfaces at that time a very very
classical conception of literature very
almost archaic literature is just a
technique of transmission restitution of
moral and material realities and you and
even another method in give you a
graphic method you have like some almost
a rhetorical reflection what what
statistic device should I use to
transmit to restitute the atmosphere of
the right and I thought that that's very
interesting because when you think of
the exchanges between anthropology in
literature you first third things you
think of vocation but I on yeah God
primitive art and indeed I mean this is
really an important aspect of the
relationship between supporting the
culture
doctrine or journal they attack directed
by better ladies where can find the you
know signatures back by anthropologist
and by Pruitt's or surrealist but forty
ethnographers the the relationship to
the trainees it's not that so it's that
effects Oliver Oliver she has not here
because writers are looking toward
anthropology because they lack the
documents they like the realities they
like was brought by a topology using it
insists it's unsettled our expectations
it reveals aspects of the experience
which ordinary life that's why that I
laid wreaths Vietnam refer but did not
refer they they love literature just
because the to tourism is a rhetorical
technique to transmit an atmosphere to
transmit a moral tonality more time
and to go back to Middle East Iran
that's a great book unfortunately but
the version of the death which is now
for sale is not the one which was
originally published which was much more
literary and with voice speaking in the
first person and talking about his
childhood and how he was in love with
his Informer and all that but he skipped
eerie words yeah the thing is that he's
really he's using F doing everything it
can to recreate I don't want to say that
to read to revive the atmosphere of the
mr. Issa and so using free free indirect
speech very long description for ethnic
faces
figure this kind of thing
no so what you just said gives us some
sense for how the specificity of
anthropology puts it into a particularly
vexed relationship with
the induction you sketch out some of the
ways that science and literature gets
configured in other domains but
anthropology has a sort of a particular
problem with this relationship to
literature through the atmosphere the
emphasis on atmosphere and moral climate
yeah the thing is actually you do it
fine I mean most of the 19th century
19th century social sciences and not
even social sciences but let's say
history for example or geography we're
facing this difficulty of restitution
the problem of how do you account for
a reality which is not always tangible
and you found that so it's there is this
there is all those methods you know buy
it buy it buy the positivist I mean all
this come from sort of positivist
the definition of successful science
even if you if you read like historians
such as signals long walk there is all
this like it's a birthday today right
very long methods to teach you how you
do history in the end there is a very
small chapter about how we're at yeah so
it's all about critical critical
critical source of the sources pretty
pretty criticism resources create
criticals also has established facts
have you establish your documents and
then in the end you have like two
paragraphs saying okay
whatever the style how would you you
know expose your results and and most of
the time they say okay you have to be
where we are the flow the flow so sort
of Co shoes you know for Johnny maddick
fear emotion that's what you find this
is you have you find this type of sort
of troubles scruples at the end of a lot
of methods and it's same for literal
history history geography actually fine
same thing that sort of recurring thing
about how do you finally expose the
results of your investigation
but the thing with anthropology is that
I think it and so bulges are facing this
difficulty more directly because for two
reasons Pickers
because of their field experience which
is still remain the core of their
discipline so and and then because they
really want to account for this idea
that the social fact is mental so in a
way I think anthropology reveals an
inherent difficulty of some sort of
documentary paradigm which used which
was applied to material realities and
this difficulty was you know sometimes
surfacing in Sciences such as history or
literal history but it suddenly burst
out with with anthropology
yeah so and what's writing is is the in
the discourse of the anthropologist of
the thirties is that on the one hand I
mean they are it's a very contradictory
discourse because I'm the one and they
keep saying ok we're not fighters
we're not writers real scientists in
Japan places for the fittest it
this is one of the first senators
material
so we are not one of those exotic you
know travelers giving impressions of
their travels but at the same time they
keep complaining that the ritual masks
the tools or whatever behind the window
panes of the museum are unable to give
an idea of the atmosphere of the society
yes Ted state quick
so and and and I try to follow that this
I mean it's sort of historical to follow
this you know it's through different
disciplines but mainly and you know it's
you know the first the first first page
of the most massive most men even
ethnography is keep saying okay nog Rafi
anthropology it is just gorgeous
c'mon you record and you've established
your record and you established
documents he says and statistician
artists
remember all the lists all the
qualification all the abilities and
approaches is to put two paths and then
in the end he says and maybe also
another list able to whatever
synonymously able to evoke evil it would
be an entire society
and that's that's why I think with who
was also saying I need to be a novelist
to talk about that
mr. Allen
so you talked earlier about this
chiasmus with the ethnographers looking
to the traditions and literary
techniques and then the mutual
fascination of the literary writers and
the others
sort of gives part of the structure of
the book which is divided into three
three parts
yes oh yeah so the books in three parts
because the first part I mean they are
it's not quite the first part is really
devoted to anthropology in French
tradition and anthropological tradition
and to this mix of attraction and
repulsion rejection of literature so
this kind of you know scruples I was
mentioning and you know ways of
misunderstanding between battalion TV
you know that I'm looking for
seeing the document as a
as a way to get out of the
representation and the reveille looking
at literature as a way to give a good
presentation so first part of it what's
interesting is that in sir it's both
fascination and rejection
we are not writers but in the same time
we are the followers of soul and which
is so yeah which is something else which
is the way French anthropologist are
telling their own history and they are
most of the time thing I shall give
themselves to goodness sauce
and it's interesting because they they
kind of wanna cut loose from the company
literature to go back to an essence and
an instrument conception of the children
saying well remember engaging century
science and literature with where you
know walking hand in hand so this is
under so this is the this kind of makes
a game between attraction and repulsion
and then so this is the second book is
devoted to specific studies of literary
supplements of second chapter amid hoar
one chapter on video chat there isn't
much other initials and then the third
part of the book is about the same type
of mixed feelings but this time the
authority from the writers towards the
anthropologist so and you can you can
find a very similar so there is some
sort of mirror structure
it's a very similar attraction and
disturbed yeah their first prison in a
way they are very interested in
anthropology and you know surrealist
where the first years of Christianity
blue and in the new law says you have
like a special week devoted to
anthropology so the writers are really
interested and and they are translating
you know poems from like Hamilton
Indians from Mexico or giving man
Akashic proverbs
so they are projected and at the same
time they are very very topology because
anthropology is you know we're competing
with the ambition
and approaching yeah man ignition yeah
it's traditional to Israeli so yeah this
is the core of the third part is called
the the co had appropriate in so this
become an appropriate AIT's a it's a
phrase from Ramon Valadez article 1935
when he talks about so he's a an uneasy
Easter one of the other leaders of the
new businesses and he tells the
conversation he starts I mean this
article is really really really
interesting and he started well I was in
Scotland you know and I had this great
conversation with it with with with this
ecologist and and we were wondering who
who has you know who is really what
should we believe when when we are
coming to a knowledge of man should we
give you them good or business geologist
and he says that's what Joanna I think
this was relocated correct
so meaning that traditionally knowledge
of man was the jurisdiction of
literature and it's pre explicit in the
19th century and of the 19th century
text when you have people like
Christopher also saying fortunately
there was no there was no life
scholarship in immerse resto whom the
domain in inalienable the poet customer
customer demand in any another the
poet's intimacy so says yeah literature
was very general you know and then
literature saw gradually its territory
Frank because of the assaults of
sciences so first of all mathematics and
physics then
Natural History then history geography
and he says fortunately we still have
one thing which is limo and of security
and again in the people twenties in the
interwar period this is some sort this
is a way of presenting literature which
is everywhere it has some points on
advanced ability when the founder of
important people talk talks about the
food of Shanghai
so feeling that the feeling that
literature is actually losing its you
know who think its territorial
jurisdiction it's the main points it's
very rightly
says okay not leukerbad other groosalugg
it can go ahead before you do so this is
this give the pattern of the third part
of the book which is so I I trace I
thought I could follow through the from
1895 until 1967
so I said it's not like a linear history
I just give like snapshots so I take
different pros
the first one is a nossa to do is to
grow old with no songs of Canon I got
some of the gate sociology that you have
on the bouton then you have on the
bottom and the ethnologist actually only
works on contesting the ambition of they
go to no Easter either saying well the
anthropologists are unable to know
Easter and because because God blessing
we've got blasted moraga frozen frozen
case for bidness prevent them from
grasping anything so that's what we put
on traces thank you have also backed I
reading so this is the opposite but I'm
reading copy can saying okay the topic
is actually the proof
once antibody is done with his
scientific work it has to become
literature so and said do you have all
those back in force movements and then
it goes up to that and the two sided
barking about mysteries and then about
claiming for in this famous will do less
your serenity idea which is to me just
another way to frame the co-head
appropriated not focusing on poets
approach who your man that's focusing on
a future but it's still the same the
same debate so yes
and so let's talk a little about a
little bit of about Libby's course
there's an important chapter in the
second part as you mentioned devoted to
twisted Chloe
of course you worked on the playoff
edition so I guess I mean I'm curious
since that is the sort of monumental
izing gesture with respect to the East
Coast and literary canonizing him as a
literary writer in a certain sense and
wondering how you see the relationship
between that gesture and between your
work on that edition and then your
reading oh but if he's close in the
chapter I mean in the book is because
part of the work of doing the play out
is to make a decision within
this and decide which texts are to be
included as literary called canonical
during text yeah well indeed I mean I
was working on the pleiad before
finishing this book and working at the
playa and also reading I mean seeing the
way the layout was received
phew
reflection I mean it gave me a lot of
things to think of because indeed the
most I mean the most usual reading of
the players of the player was a met with
an unexpected success which is really
surprising given the text the text in
that they are are not that fancy
and they're not even the easiest Porter
in his thoughts were so it was it was
as far as the sales go it was a great
success and the reception in press was
to say okay now we got we we have we are
getting rid of an amateur special
attention we're getting rid of the for
world news tiring volumes of Russia and
we have the most you know like the
madness was the man we are we get we are
we have live East Coast without the
structure is this that's cool you know
that's you know we're supposed to be at
the structuralism and so that's a weight
was read and to me it's a very odd
fights were really both two ladies were
thinking in itself because actually this
was also the late
the latex like the story of links
the Jesus father I put you loosen so I
guess so you would say in your choice I
mean the choice of text for the playoff
you were actually trying to be somewhat
true to the argument that you're making
in the book but it was received in a way
that distorted yeah other things that I
didn't make the choice I mean the choice
was made by policeman but it was like so
if you could you know he was there
I mean he did not intervene at all in
the critical addition process itself but
he gave you wrote a letter to give him a
sec okay to me to get him up
offered able to be published that the
yeah he did not refuse
and if someone some leaving mother ever
refused that
and and getting our example wanted to
have race in history which is maybe
there was easier steps but maybe it was
over
it's not that easy but and if you
suppose answered saying okay the ideal
platform II would be and gave this
mystical peak so this is this was the
only intervention in the the critical
addition process so I didn't choose it
but push and today because it was and I
try to understand the motivation of
ladies for selecting his own works to be
lyin eyes or canonized was part of the
puzzles
the present student to the collection so
but anyway to me leave your thoughts
quite escape this opposition between
science and literature I mean he has
this this idea that there is no such
discontinuity between
the sort of knowledge she can gain from
a literary text and the sort of
knowledge we can gain from a social
sciences tax so yeah this is the but you
can't really I mean the reception was
still that literature was I mean the
reception was very with a really suited
better effect because basically what
journalists were saying I mean few words
were saying was actually what that I was
saying in 1956 about pieces would be
saying this is the evidence that
at some points anthropology has to keep
up and
divorce to purchase all good
soon I assume you try to start to combat
that perception
yeah yeah well you know this yeah I mean
I mean
still the introduction is a little bit
about that and I hope that yeah you know
it will it's hard to teach you to fight
some sort of bad
it's a powerful machine yeah so when
they and everyone is saying oh that's
great we are getting rid of structure
you can say well
so you are as most people here know
teaching in the Department of mentioned
romance pathology there's Columbia and
you've been here for a couple of years
and so I'm wondering sort of have the
experience you insist on in the book on
the accept stop Paul says both with
respect to the consumption of
ethnography that is quite different gets
played out differently than in the
United States and
for example and also the specificity of
the French conception of literature and
so you know from amor by Maya graphical
perspective I'm wondering if your
experiences here in the Academy you are
more generally living here have affected
your sense of that
or the sort of American if the American
approach to anthropology is well yeah
this is I mean thank you for mentioning
that because that this is I know that
the talk presentation
anthropology but it's one of the
important things I came to realize is
that the way the issue literature and
anthropology is frayed draping varies
according to the national traditions
traditions so my my point is that it's
not quite the same here in the US and in
Great Britain and in France so I don't
so should I say something about
okay so just a word about this French
specificity on the anthropological said
it's a very philosophical and it's again
I mentioned the fact that it was all the
refers are nostalgic of the
Enlightenment or even more than the
enactment of innocence so they read
think of it themselves as the the
reenactment in the 20th century of a
tradition which had been lost
so they have this very theoretical
conception anthropology which you can
recognizing the in the typical French
object you know this is tender passe
kinship systems savage mind all that
it's not it's not like typical British
object so there is the downside of that
is of course that the French
anthropology has trouble coping with a
critical illness this is the main
reproach coming from us I mean as soon
as the twenties people like Robert Louis
River we're saying okay guys that's
great all those things always thought
about representation but maybe should do
only work now and actually this was when
he was here in Europe
the rapid-fire seven hero thing is long
very powerful article about French
called French sauce ecology and it's an
answer to this preachy coming from
especially the US and and one of the
things that they will say is that we are
we are we are catching up we are
catching up that's true
this this and she has this very very
pretentious saying okay you know British
anthropology has collected so many facts
that now they will need someone to
organize these gave us so you actually
need a theoretical anthropology path so
there is this so this is for the French
and so political specificity and as far
as literature goes the thing is that
French conception of literature is digit
is an absolute it's a it's it's not
that's why I mean the truth is not like
culture the culture which would be
dialogue with scientific culture
that the pattern that British patterns
inherited from I mean from the 19th
century of the the idea of two cultures
the two cultures it's um something which
is different to a French tradition and
also as as as is foreign to the French
tradition all the development even until
now
in particular the science war is
something which was the reason it's not
did not affect at all French actor
Demian and so and this is this party
comes I think from the fact that
literature is not a culture it's say
it's like it yet you even for I mean for
the writers but also the scholars of the
philosophers and my things is right I
mean he's right when he says that he is
like very similar phrase okay and so so
literature has sort of her essential
ambition which is to feel mentioned in
the in the annual deportment newsletter
the phrase may write the sentence by men
understand saying many characters who
are to succeed in Stanley's existence
delicacy
don't miss it so Faculty of thought in
the writing and and indeed that's why
that's why the writers are so feel so
uncomfortable with with the development
of anthropology is that they're there
addition to Omaha say to certain cell
phone say was kind of called into
question by
and in a way and even who further and
think of French teacher in the 30s of
going back to something more specific
historical faster in the thirties is
characterized by the movement which is
trying to regain to regain this
disability to think of everything human
nothing is for right to the children and
you can think of that you can think of
another that way it's more circulation
as a way to again
we could've created RealPlayer to
reconquer a tale to reiterate which had
been threatened by the major butcher
so I guess I guess my last question
before opening opening it up to all of
you would be of course there's a certain
amount of concern recently with the
status of the humanities
it stays with recent events such as SUNY
Albany cutting their their French and a
number of other important humanities
programs also in Great Britain and it
seems to me that you're so a number in
in our department where we're talking
about this issue and possibly planning
to try to respond to it with
it seems to me that your book has quite
a bit to say about these issues of how
one might think about the status of
communities in relation to Sciences in
the hard sciences
do you feel that yeah that's it
I think thanks to show something is
there the idea of personal videos but I
give portunity of Sciences as well as
paternity of literature are just
delusions that they are deeply I mean
deeply intricate and it's it's it's
really you I mean it's a it's a mistake
but also I mean it's an evolution to
think of you know humanities as
something you know for effect pleasure
moral education on the one hand and then
like Sciences for applications and be
useful in the world because actually I
think if you think of a society talk
about you know too much discursive
spaces then you can you can come to
realize that this disgust cursive spaces
are really connected together and that
the connection is pretty intricate
sometimes
you know that there is a deep connection
between the museum the museum base at
Rabaul here the 30s or you know and when
I say that it sort of I mean
positivistic ideology in general on the
one hand the trade attempts contribute
to your tent so you know what I would
say that thinking again it's thinking of
humanities just as you know something
you you would have pleasure on weekends
and after being there before going to
bed like nice meetings it's it's just a
complete mistake not only about the
literature itself but also that about
science you know about the way science
works and not to mention totally naive
conception of science as theory event
having applications as if as if
applications of science was progressing
you know
be obliged to really say oh this is its
kind of its really battle and did those
I did I said it was my last question but
what more did those ideas how do those
ideas about your teaching that's why I
need your research but when you when
you're teaching is there a way of
bringing that about thinking about
discursive spaces and dispatching
because of course it's much more
difficult to read you know the types of
text that you're dealing with in your
book in a literature class or anything
yeah well not in itself I guess but I I
try to always you especially when I was
teaching with I tried a little bit on
widget and amenities which have been
great books that were quite big books
class trying to show him some sort of
historical contacts now just a minute
- kind of a cliche but still it's really
important to get a sense
like context the very vague thing but
you know the type of expectations of the
reader at the time the the conceptual
landscape in which each writer is
inscribing itself himself this kind of
thing so those
okay I'm sure that there are questions
from the
you